as a chef i know it's not what you spend
on ingredients but results on the plate
that count
using cheap cuts and leftovers and
working them hard in the kitchen
gives you food in a budget that tastes a
million bucks
first up my flavor-packed lamb with
fried bread
whether i'm cooking high-end dishes or
rustic dishes trust me it all has to be
impressive so
this lamb dish proves that you don't
have to spend a fortune to create
delicious food
first off put the pan on
this is a lamb steak and it's cut just
above the leg just
here because you can see that delicious
bone running through the center and
that's full of marrow so that just gives
the lamb a nice added sweet flavor just
take your knife
cut through each end this stops the
lamb steak from buckling so therefore it
cooks
evenly and colors beautifully salt
and pepper lamb needs quite a lot of
help with the pepper so
be quite generous with the pepper and
just pat that down
the pan is just under smoke on the
outside now put the oil in
get that pan really nice and hot because
this is a cheap cut so
i'm depending on the color of the lamb
steak to really sort of
impart a lot of flavor that's the noise
you want to hear
you can't hear that noise don't drop a
steak in put a little bit of garlic in
there
not chopped garlic just whole cloves the
garlic
lightly crushed don't even waste time
peeling them in tongs lift up
that bit of fat around the back that's
the top of the leg
tilt the pan and let all that fat render
rendering is a chef's term that means
melting the fat
it works brilliantly when you're cooking
a rib eye as well turn it over
that color beautiful now it looks like
an expensive cut
and we've got that nice even sear all
over
as it's cooking just tilt the pan and
vase
and basting the lamb steak just means
you're sort of adding all that nice
scented garlic olive oil back into the
lamb
diesel now take the lamb out
let the lamb restaurant
[Music]
now for the perfect rustic crouton
so this bread's quite firm a couple of
days old just slice it
straight down the center
dice it up put it into a bowl
season it beautifully
from there i'm gonna add some milk
sounds strange adding milk to crouton
but it just gives it that nice
rich creamy texture and just let that
milk sort of absorb into the bread
while that's soaking i'm gonna make the
dressing go back to that initial
garlic that was in the pan look at that
beautiful into the pest and water and
chives
anchovies go brilliantly well with lamb
i want that nice salty
vinegary flavor and a bit of kick some
capers
the little baby cats very sweet now
just pound that to a nice paste
that smells incredible next some dijon
mustard
a nice teaspoon and a half in a little
bit of red wine vinegar
two tablespoons and then our extra
virgin olive oil
now it's got that heat in there i've got
a nice roasted garlic a real hearty
chunky vinaigrette that sort of seeps
into that lamb
some fresh parsley
crunch up the parsley delicious flavor
parsley in
nice now get your pan hot for the
croutons
olive oil in the pan grab the croutons
and squeeze all that excess milk out not
too hard
i don't want them dry and in
and then just fry them and the milk
inside these croutons give it a nice
spongy
creamy delicious flavor
that's the color i want nice
now take them out and lightly drain them
a little bit of kitchen roll
onto the board out
a plateman just take this amazing
vinaigrette
and spread it get those croutons listen
to them
like little boulders hitting the plate
the lamb let's sit that one
next one on
the rest of the croutons on
now use all those little bits and my
chef in paris would kill me right now if
you saw me using those because
they're the ugly scraps that customers
should never see but but they're the
best bits
croutons on and then just
drop that sauce on all those little bits
of the lamb and there that is a perfect
way
of taking a cheap cut into the premier
league of dishes
for dishes that always pack a punch
without costing a fortune
simple and cheap delicious ingredients
like sausages are great
and you don't need a lot of them to get
stunning dishes that taste incredible
so spend your money wisely and you can
have amazing midweek meals
that don't cost the earth my next recipe
is all about great flavors
and it's as cheap and easy to make as it
is delicious
spicy sausage rice whatever you're
cooking
the secret to making great food is to
ensure you're locking every last
ounce of flavor in that pan and this
spicy sausage rice does exactly that
[Music]
take these spicy sausages and pierce
that skin
because i want all that delicious spicy
sausage meat out of this casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas bread
onion
less acidic than a big white spanish
onion
and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages
to sort of really help flavor the onions
onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion
it's really important to sort of give
them five to six minutes
in the pan so you can really start to
caramelize them
and now for my pepper slice around
wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of little core
those pips in the center
no fine diced pepper the rice is going
to be cooking for 20 minutes so
i want the veg to sort of have texture
after it's cooked
peppers in a bit of garlic two nice
cloves
just slap down off of the shell
garlic in
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in
everything cools down and you'll end up
boiling the peppers and the onions of
the garlic so
heat up to maximum and then just make a
well
in the center in
now start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skins off
and the real flavor of that spicy
italian sausage
is going to come through what's great
about this recipe is that you can use
any type of sausage to get the flavor
and the heat you want
i've gone for the spicy italian but it's
just as good with merguez or sweet so
a teaspoon paprika in give it that
really nice smoky flavor
rice in and we're gonna sort of
basically sear the rice we call it
in the kitchen blasting the rice where
we sort of soda the rice for 30 seconds
and it takes on all that flavor
next white wine so the wine sort of
deglazes the pan and washes all that
flavor
from the bottom of the pan into the rice
stock in
bring it up to the boil turn it down and
let it simmer
[Music]
double stop to rice turn that gas down
and let it simmer for 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now
get ready to finish it slice spring
onions
diced sweet juicy tomatoes and roughly
chop earthy flat leaf parsley
spring is in tomatoes in off with the
gas
really important otherwise everything
becomes overcooked flat leaf parsley
in but look at the volume in that pan
now
that is an amazing way to take spicy
italian sausages to a completely
different level
[Music]
beautiful
you